私は究極の
循環型社会を釣りたくて8年前にペンチャー企業を
作りました
いわもとみちこと言います
育ち盛りの意地の父を入れもあります
白のですね炎は
なんかいい匂いがしませんか
なんか輝いて見えませんか
このですね炎は皆さんの今着ている服から
by を得たボールを取り出して燃やしてるんですね
この技術は
8年前に
世界で初めて
開発し
実用化に成功した技術です
えっとですね
ここの向上はですね
服を入れて
水を入れてコースを入れてエタノールを作っています
ですからで分別入らないというのがですねリサイクルのコンセプトになっています
で日本では今現在
100万トンの
衣類がですね廃棄されています100万トンとはどれくらいかといいますと
ガーデンリサイクル法の冷蔵庫洗濯機
うクーラーとか大きいのありますあれで65万トンなんですね
それよりも多いのに全然リサイクルが住んではこれは日本だけじゃないです
アメリカやヨーロッパも同じなんですね
でこの
弊社の技術を使うとですね薬
100万トンから70万キロリットルのバイオエタノールが生産することができます
約7割変換していきます
次に
日本国内で家庭から出るゴミてどれくらい変わりますか
4500万トン年間配されています
で次の技術はですねこの4500万トンを分別なくすべて資源に変える技術開発をです
ね
この5年間で行ってきました
それが出来ましてこの4500万トンを
請求と同じ
プラスチックの
セキュと同じクオリティはですねぷらーシックに戻すことができます
で今の技術士と約1000万トンの
プラスチックがですねできるんです
1000万トンといいますと
国内の総使用量です日本の
車
ふく
文具玩具
席をですね1的持つ花は咲く
これがですねできるんですね
企業から出る日はですねその10倍あるんです
ですから資源大国というのは埋蔵量から技術力になってきました
ここで言いたいのはこの世界には
ゴミは存在しないですね
すべてのごみは資源なんです
これが大事なんですね
せっかく羽田に来ましたので
飛行機の話をさせてもらいます
今現在ですねこの上空にたくさんの飛行気が飛んでいます
またたくさんの人の夢や希望を乗せてですね
飛行機が
トンネルんですけども
8私たちの技術
からですねジェット燃料を作ることができまして
皆さんの着てる100万今の二からですね約70万キロリットルの
アーチがごめんなされ
a 棟ジェット燃料をですね作ることができます
で東京からええ
入浴この距離がですね約1番1戦 k ですねそこで使うジェット燃料は約120キロ
リットルと言われます
この a
弊社の技術を使いますと
約100万トンのですね衣類から5000回以上のジェット燃料をですね作ることが
可能になりました
ですから技術はですね非常に大事
っていうことがですねまあここで皆さんにですね
お知らせしたいと思っております
次に究極のですね循環型社会を作りはもう一つキーワードがいます
それは
消費者参加型なんですね
みなさん参加型なんです
皆さんをどんな風に参加したらいいのかなと思って
アンケートとっていました
そうすると
買った店に
洋服を持っていきたいがった店におもちゃを持っていきたい
そういうあの答えがですね一番多かったんですね
で2つ目はですねこれにキャッチフレーズをつけようと
火を使う捨てるから
これからはいサイクル化を使う
こういう消費行動ですねやっぱり変えていかないといけないと思いました
ですからリサイクルしにお店に行って買って使う
これがですねまぁ一番いいんじゃないかということで
日本中のですねお店に交渉に行くんですね
イオンさん
消費者は買った店でリサイクル者になって
7さん
消費者はですねええ
実感リサイクルの実感をしたいんだって
スタバ3用品さんいろんなですねお店に入って消費さをですね巻古墳し首を作りました
でこんな風にして子供たちがで全楽しく参加できる
場所がですね今提供しています
ここがですね今現在ですね衣類の回収をしているところです
メガネもしています
音楽と環境なんです楽しくするんですね
で幼虫にもですね回収ボックスを置いてます
子供たちにはおもちゃからおもちゃになるんだよと
だから大事に使ったらちゃんとリサイクルいまぁそうねって言う
啓蒙活動をやっています
この考え方をですねインドでやってみました
もののたくさんある日本ではよく集まります
さてインドで圧バウんだろうか
仮説を立てました
そうしたらですね日本以上に集まったんですね
これは大事なのは
きちっと湯さえくるの話をすることなんです
地下資源に頼らない
こういう社会がですねできると技術でできると
だからきちっと集めてくださいねという説明をした後の回収実験だったんでよく集まり
ました
だからちゃんと人に舌に伝えることが大事なというふうに思いました
今現在では
国内外の大手150社の企業や団体さんがですね
協力いただいております
この100号車150社のおかげで皆さんはですね
気軽に参加できるんですね
これが大事です
さて
コンビはですね全てる資源なん
こういう社会ができたらですね
どんなことを想像しますか
今現在
世界で起きている
争い
そのをもたる原因はですね
資源争奪
だと言われています
4件
争奪のおかげ聖霊ですね
たくさんの人が
すぐ場所を追われて
たくさんの人がですね命を奪われています
この
社会をですね作っているので我々の生活なんですね
ですからまあ現実を出てきちっと見てえっとさて僕らのできる
4件
争奪のない世界をですね作るにはどうしたらいいだろうというふうなですね
答えがここにあるんです
技術はできました
どんどんどんどんですね皆さんが参加する
場所がですね増えていってます
今からはですね皆さんは
二サイクルをするだけで
戦争のですね起こらない社会がですね実現できるうえです
私はですね
この社会を
本気で作りたいと思って強風ところですね出させていただいたんですね
ですから
今からの
社会はですね地下資源に耐える
社会じゃなくて地上資源だけで十分もありますので
みなさんこれを認識してですねぜひぜひぜひ
リサイクルに参加していただきたいと思っています
一人で運営この社会は作れません
皆さんの思い
心
音がの楽しいこういう社会ですね
ぜひ処理作れを作りたいと思っています今日どうもありがとうございました